be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so as we pick up with part 2 of Batman
with DC rebirth I was scrolling through
the comments of the last video and
somebody to ask the question what
happened to the new 52 Batman and this
is kind of an indication to me that not
everybody is aware of what went on with
Batman in the new 52 and so what I want
to do is take I guess the first part of
this video to kind of clear this up and
to make things easy to understand with
this character because Batman can be a
bit confusing when it comes to the new
52 so as we know in 2011 DC rebooted
everything the new 52 was a line wide
reboot whether you love it or hate it
that's that's what we got and what do
you see originally established was that
it had only been 5 years between the
time that superheroes first emerged and
the start of the new 52 now with regards
to DC rebirth the only thing we really
know right now is that it was actually
10 years that were stolen from people's
lives and that was all done supposedly
at dr. Manhattan but again this is a
very primitive story we have no real
idea of what direction DC is going in
with that and so that's that's really
the only thing we know I can't really
offer you any more info besides that but
virtually everybody in DC Comics got a
reboot the Teen Titans were rebooted you
know Superman was rebooted Wonder Woman
Aquaman the whole nine yards the only
two characters who were not rebooted was
the Green Lantern and Batman and that
was simply because of the fact that the
comics were selling so well it didn't
make any sense to reboot him it was a
classic adage if it works don't fix it
and so with the character of Batman what
DC did is they came back and they retold
his origin story we got that in Batman
zero year and it told us what was going
on in the life of Bruce Wayne from the
time his parents died up until the time
he became Batman when Batman issue
number one came out with a new 52 the
issue with this is there was no
explanation on his backstory there was
no ever I guess no not really his
backstory there was no explanation about
all the stories that had happened before
he was you know before the new 52 we
didn't know if stories like hush had
actually happened we didn't know his
stories like nightfall if The Killing
Joke if things like that had actually
happened in the new 52 instead DC just
left it open-ended and they're still
doing that what DC says is none of the
stories that happened in Batman's
history before the new 52 actually
happened unless they say they did and so
during Batman eternal for example we
the villain hush returned and DC
established that the storyline hush did
happen in the new 52 we had reference to
the Killing Joke in the story of Barbara
Gordon Batgirl zone line of comics and
so we know that Killing Joke happened
and we had actually seen reference to
the events of nightfall when Bane broke
Batman's back and that was referenced
what DC is basically telling us is that
whenever they reference a story from the
pourer from before the new 52 that story
happened in the five year window and so
this Batman that we're seeing right now
is the pre new 52 Batman it's just DC's
kind of left it open as to whether or
not the stories that happened before the
new 52 actually took place I know it's a
little confusing it's a little weird not
really sure why they chose to do that
but the best rule of thumb to take here
is that unless an event like nightfall
is referenced unless an event like hush
or like The Killing Joke is referenced
it's best to assume it just didn't
happen I know it kind of boggles the
mind in terms of like all that stuff
happened over the course of five years
but you know it's you got to kind of go
with it for what it is
you know it's it's comics don't think
about it too hard you'll make your head
explode that's that's how I live my life
when it comes to comics but the fact
remains that now that were painting up
with issue number two in the last video
we basically just talked about how
Batman was in Gotham City it's his
normal round wear-and-tear where he's
saving the city of course Duke Thomas is
the new Robin to take the place of
Damian Wayne at least at the moment
anyway and and what's basically
happening right now is we're continuing
the event of the arrival of two
characters that came at the end of the
last video the first one referencing
himself as Gotham and the second one
being Gotham girl and so what we do is
we pick up with kind of with with
solomon grundy basically if those of you
guys who don't know solomon grundy is i
would go as far as to say he's DC's
Incredible Hulk just because of the fact
that he predates Incredible Hulk as far
as I'm aware but he is one of the
strongest characters in the DC Universe
and he's a very intimidating foe but he
always has a mantra that goes along with
him and anybody that's read DC Comics
and is familiar with solomon grundy
knows that mantra of course a mantra
being born on a monday christened on a
tuesday married on a wednesday took ill
on a thursday grew worse on friday died
on saturday buried on Sunday that's his
thing and so while this is happening
while solomon grundy is basically
tearing a part of this statue in gotham
city Gotha
and an gotham are both trying to defend
it as best they can they're trying to I
guess stave off solomon grundy and what
this is designed to do what Tom King is
basically showing us is two things the
first is that Batman isn't necessarily
against them being there but the second
is that they're very inexperienced and
we would expect this
you know Batman has fought solomon
grundy on a multitude of occasions and
so one he knows the best way to deal
with him he knows the best way to
interact with him and he knows his
weaknesses
before Gotham in Gotham girl they don't
know this all they know is that solomon
grundy is just a bad guy who's trying to
tear things up and so what ends up
happening here is of course Batman
subdue solomon grundy by using his
momentum against him now this is
actually one of the funny things i was
having this conversation with a friend
of mine and he had read batman edition
number 2 and his thought was that batman
had actually picked up solomon grundy
and of course the answer to that is
absolutely not
Solomon Grundy's way too heavy for
Batman to lift this is someone just an
example where Solomon Grundy's running a
Batman Batman uses the momentum and
flips him over on the ground but of
course Solomon Grundy is also someone
that doesn't necessarily fear Batman but
even if it's on a base level understands
that Batman's not a guy to be trifled
with
and so what Batman does is once he
hasn't pinned down of course he says
that that you're Solomon Grundy gets up
it's going to hurt a whole lot more now
this is where the inexperience of Gotham
and Gotham girl come into play and this
is where Tom King tells us Batman isn't
really against them being there of
course
what Batman says is that they were
wasting too much time that in Batman's
mind it's all a matter of calculations
it's all a matter of figuring things out
as all a matter of knowing what's going
to happen within a reasonable timeframe
and he tells them that because they had
wasted so much time because solomon
grundy was moving so fast if Batman had
not intervened they would have resulted
in the death of a homeless man at least
we presume he's homeless um but we would
have resulted in the death of this man
and so what Batman says is he's been
watching them but they've been doing the
best they can to keep Gotham City safe
and this makes sense because Batman
wouldn't simply allow just two people to
show up in Gotham and start acting in a
superhero fashion without keeping an eye
on them even if he doesn't necessarily
intervene he would definitely be aware
of what's going on and that's what's
happened here Batman's been watching
them and he simply says they're doing
good they're doing some very good things
but the goal is to do better now he
doesn't give them an actual idea of what
to do on how to do better and this is
kind of a funny thing with Batman we
cuz unless you are Robin the Batman
doesn't really you know take you under
his wing and teach you everything step
by step with Robin of course he does
that because the Batman's mind Robin is
designed to be his successor one day Tim
Drake Dick Grayson Stephanie Brown
Carrie Kelly Damian Wayne they're all
designed to be successors or at least
they were trained to be successors for
Batman they all went off on their own
individual story arts and of course as
we know Dick Grayson went on to become
Nightwing Tim great Tim Drake I believe
went on to be Red Robin but we know that
they've taken on their own identities
but if the worst case scenario happened
and Batman died
any one of them would be able to take up
the mantle in his place especially
someone like Dick Grayson but the issue
here is that with Gotham and Gotham
grill not being given a clear
understanding of what it is that they're
supposed to do they ask for it you know
Gotham simply says if we're not doing
what it is that we need to do in order
to be effective superheroes for the city
of Gotham then tell us what we need to
do tell us how to be you know crime
fighters tell us how to fight
intelligently as opposed to just kind of
being you know a broadsword swinging
through the city of Gotham in bad guys
and so what we do is we transition later
and we pick up with Bruce Wayne when he
is you know monitoring various footage
radagast certain forms of footage that
he has on Gotham and Gotham girl and in
his mind it's kind of a tough situation
because he has largely been the sole
protector of Gotham for quite some time
he's had sidekicks he's had people that
helped him but when it came down to it
we as readers always look to Batman as
the sole savior of Gotham City but to
have two superheroes here who are for
all intents and purposes more or less a
version of Superman they may not
necessarily be as strong but they fly
they have you know super hearing I guess
ultra hearing you know they have a you
know incredible vision and so on and so
forth they have all the feats of
Superman at a you know to a lesser
degree and of a different name it's kind
of a situation of is Batman really even
useful here anymore
if the time comes when they are trained
to the epitome of what it means to be a
superhero at a time comes when they are
as good as Batman in terms of being able
to analyze the situation then being able
to neutralize that situation then of
what use would Batman be it would be as
if Superman showed up in Gotham City and
said he was going to start protecting it
but at the same time he also realizes
that sometimes he just needs help that
with the incident of the plane that with
the various asteroids and things like
that with all the different threats that
had faced Gotham City if they were
beyond Batman's
normal ability to take care of that
Gotham and Gotham girl had done it they
had basically you know they had save the
planet
you know you I guess diverted asteroid
so on and so forth they were doing the
things that Bruce Wayne couldn't do and
in his mind it's a struggle because he's
facing he's looking at these two and
he's basically seeing the fact that he's
becoming obsolete he's seeing a Gotham
City that no longer needs him this is
one of the reasons why Tom King riding
is so cool because we don't really see
this very often we see stories where
Batman goes against overwhelming odds
but we don't really see stories where
Batman sits down and has to ponder the
fact that he could be obsolete the fact
that he wouldn't really matter anymore
obsolescence I'm not really sure that's
water now but I'm going to use it as a
word I'm going to make it one if it's
not but anyway with Alfred showing up
outfit of course you know brings us back
to earth he brings us back to you know
the everyday life of Batman that's one
of the great things about that Alfred in
this story is he always keeps us
anchored to the present and he basically
tells us that in Wayne Manor there's
about 250 guests who were all there to
see Bruce Wayne for a you know a
Children's Hospital gala that they put
together then this is just you know of
course we don't really see Bruce of
Bruce Wayne go often do you know
performing that gala cuz we don't really
need to instead Tom Kean deviates our
attention to building another plot
building an upcoming set of events and
what he tells us is that with
Commissioner Gordon working over you
know staying over for about two or three
hours to do whatever it is that he does
in the Gotham City Police Department
that there is apparently a man who is
down there waiting for him and when this
man comes up to meet me Commissioner
Gordon
what he says is that he is the person
that set solomon grundy free now our
initial thought or at least my initial
thought when I first heard this was that
maybe this guy was just some kind of you
know villain mastermind that with him
drawing some kind of a blade that he was
actually going to kill Commissioner
Gordon I would have found that hard to
believe this early and Tom King's run
but that was my initial thought is
that's what he was intending to do
instead he doesn't tell us that the what
he tells us is that his name is Bob
Castro that he served in the military
but the reason why he said solomon
grundy free was because of Solomon
Grundy's extreme strength and that he
had been warned that the monster men are
coming now
we don't get anything more than this
from this guy Bob Castro and the reason
why is because Bob takes the knife and
he stabs himself in the neck with it and
kills himself now this is really kind of
cool here because in a lot of Batman
stories we usually have like the one you
know the exposition the one point where
the guy comes in and says here's
everything you need to know about events
that are coming up instead
Tom King doesn't do that he's very Zak
sir I'm sorry he's very Scott Schneider
in that way then the sense that he's
kind of building up to a major plot
thread and we just sort of have to read
things in order to understand what all
is going on but what we treat what we do
here is we transition back to Bruce
Wayne at the gala and Bruce Wayne
receives the bat-signal
and so while he is spending time with
what appears to be a very attractive
woman he basically takes off he leaves
and the result is that he ends up having
somewhat of a conversation with Duke
Duke of course you know carries on the
conversation a bit with Alfred but in
the end he says it because of the
bat-signal because of everything that's
going on that he basically needs to
leave now this is one of the other cool
things too is he gives us some insight
in how he views Gotham and Gotham girl
we as readers know that Bruce Wayne has
a very hard time trusting anybody in
fact he trusts nobody and even says that
that he doesn't trust Alfred now this is
a lie we know that Bruce Wayne trust
Alfred with his life in fact is you know
Alfred's been such a long part of Bruce
Wayne's history that unless you're
reading all-star Batman you have no
reason to distrust Alfred
I'm not going to spoil that at the
moment if you haven't read all star
Batman you definitely need to go check
it out but the fact remains here that
you know Bruce Wayne says that he does
not trust Gotham and Gotham girl now it
doesn't mean that he thinks they're bad
it's simply that he's waiting to see
what goes on he's playing it smart he's
playing the long game and this is this
is a hallmark of Bruce Wayne he always
does that whenever he encounters anybody
new he always plays a long game he
always waits to see what's going on to
see what their motives are before he
really begins to extend any measure of
trust to them in fact we've been seeing
that with Superman with the pre new 52
Superman living in the new 52 continuity
during the son of Superman story that I
went over Bruce Wayne says flat-out that
they don't know him
they don't know that version of Superman
they know the other version of sick man
who died they fought alongside him but
they don't know this pre new 52 Superman
and so they don't really have a reason
to trust him but they will so because of
the fact that he has
everything you can to prove that he's a
legitimate guy much like this with
Gotham girl and Gotham you know when
they show up at the bat-signal Jim
Gordon is initially afraid he's like
what in the world is going on here
you're not Bruce Wayne you're not Batman
and Batman simply says don't worry about
it they're with him and so what is it
happening is Jim Gordon basically tells
them what all's taking place you know
what all is happening that there was a
man who showed up that you know killed
himself
after he claimed that there that the
monster men were coming and he initially
asked Gotham and Gotham girl do they
know anything that's been going on
strange anything that would indicate
that you know there is a there are some
kind of enemy force that are showing up
in Gotham City
now of course Gotham and Gotham girls
say no and and Batman says no he doesn't
know either but they all sort of
reference the the instance or the rocket
was shot of the plane and the person who
had shot that rocket had also committed
suicide and so what this seems to
indicate is that perhaps there's a
series of events that are unfolding this
indicates that maybe all these
individuals work for the monster men but
in some former fashion they seem to be
tied in to the concept of the monster
man and they ended up committing acts in
their own name now what's really cool
about this too and these what we're
gonna see what the end of this story is
if I were to hazard a guess and of
course you know not spoiling anything
you know to just sort of live in the
moment to sort of live in right now if I
were to hazard a guess I would say well
maybe it's because of the fact that all
these individuals are these these people
are part of a larger plan they've been
assigned tasks and they're carrying
these tasks out but whatever the case
may be
in the end Batman basically bails out
without any of them knowing this is
actual it's really cool and again this
kind of points to the inexperience of
Gotham and Gotham girl you know
Commissioner Gordon is used to Batman
just vanishing up in smoke just
disappearing and going off to do his own
thing Gotham and Gotham grow are not
used to this not only that despite their
abilities they can't find Batman
anywhere now the Wii U's comic book
readers know that this is most likely
due to the fact that Batman has honed
his skills in such a way that he can
avoid Superman if he wanted to but the
fact remains here that with him
vanishing this is just kind of Batman be
Batman is not really designed to be an
extremely important moment it's just
designed to be something a little funny
something a little interesting you know
- for us to get a bit of a laugh out of
but the fact remains that what we do
here is we switch to another location
oh we initially pick up with a guy who's
not really named and this man is simply
just answering questions he's shown
images of his face where he's scared
where he's happy he's sad and he's angry
and he's being asked are you scared are
you happy are you sad and are you angry
at least I'm he replies yes professor
and what we learned is that he's
actually talking to professor Hugo
Strange now this is not the biggest part
the biggest you know kind of into the
story reveal here is that hero strange
seems to be working in accordance with
the United States government and Amanda
Waller of The Suicide Squad and so this
is just one of those instances where the
plot thickens where things become a lot
more complicated and so what we'll do is
we'll find out in the next video of
course where this line of thought is
leading us to and yeah it's pretty cool
so far like the story is actually pretty
interesting but if you guys enjoy this
make sure you drop a like make sure you
hit the subscribe button to join the Rob
core and yeah leave a comment down below
tell me what you guys think so far about
a Batman rebirth and I will catch you
guys later peace
[Music]
you